14 divided by
any takers what should we put into it
i reckon seven would be a good choice
what's 14 divided by seven how many
sevens
go into 14. the answer is two two
good yeah okay good jot that down write
that down 14 divided by seven equals two
so therefore fourteen
is seven times two that's no surprise
that's good
okay can you write down this as well
so let me just i'm going to keep this on
a running thing along the side okay so
i've got
14 divided by 7 is 2
so 14 is seven times two
okay sure that problem all right now how
about if
here right let me change one of the
numbers okay and i think you guys all
know what
is going to happen right let me get rid
of this 14 over here
suppose i make this seven negative
negative okay now hold on a second last
lesson we did
multiplication of integers with
negatives right
negative seven times two what's the
answer
negative 14. good okay so wait a second
that means that sorry i've got now i've
got
minus 14 equals minus 7 times
2 okay that means this
let me put some brackets there to make
things a bit clearer
minus 14 divided by
negative 14 divided by negative seven
equals two yeah
yep so if you divide a negative number
by a negative
you get a positive okay
let's try another one let's try another
one
i'm going to come back i like that one
that's okay we'll include it right what
if i change this one as well
no what if i change this one to a
negative
we did a double negative over here
didn't we and they canceled out so the
answer is
14. okay
so 14 equals
negative seven times negative
two cool yeah so now what do you think i
should write do you need me to turn that
yes do you reckon we can do it yes
okay so a positive number divided by
a negative gives me
another negative
what about here what have i got i've got
negative divided by
negative is equal to
positive yep and this one
um we're almost there positive divided
by
negative now have a look i've got three
these are what we call cases
different versions of the same kind of
thing i'm missing one case what case am
i missing
plus plus minus minus negative
positive negative what's the last one
it should be negative divided by
positive okay now what do we think will
happen
what do we think will happen well shall
we shall we use our
set up here
okay so what are we gonna have we want a
negative here and a positive here
and we're going to try and work out what
happens right
well let's turn around
okay we want a negative here so minus
14.
and a positive here seven
so seven times what number here's
negative fourteen
and the answer is negative two
i wrote down minus 14 equals
7 times negative 2. so minus 14 divided
by 7
equals negative 2. it equals a negative
okay let's try and gather up all our
results
in one nice neat place you drew one of
these before
but you drew it from multiplication do
you remember that yes so we had
we had multiplication up here right so
now we're going to do it like this
not on that board anymore i just ruined
it okay what are our results
positive divided by positive we said was
positive
okay negative divided by positive that's
the one we just did
negative positive divided by negative
that's this one here
negative and i think you can guess that
one all right there's our table
i suppose i should
hold on a second this
looks sush this looks familiar
actually can anyone recognize it
yesterday
it's exactly the same as this guy why is
that
because it's it's because multiplication
and division are the same
thing looked at in different ways
oh what i could do with 20 cents okay so
what's that equation right this is how
we can do
multiplication and division of positives
and negatives and it's all happy
okay